governments make it their mission to
improve the quality of life for all of
their citizens so when it comes to needs
like benefits enrollment housing
assistance permits and licenses case
documents can pile up and quickly become
difficult to manage
that's why document capture and case
management helps government agencies
provide better services to its citizens
one agency was able to reduce
information loss and eliminate filing
errors process 90% of cases within the
same day deliver services to its
citizens 31% faster than before and gain
a single view of every citizen across
any of its 34 branches the essential
documents are now right at the
fingertips of caseworkers and citizens
are getting the assistance they need
quickly and efficiently
that's ECM for enhanced customer
experience
[Music]
you